Estamos en el problema 32. Cuál es la solución a esta ecuación que es 1 más 1 entre
"x" cuadrada igual a 3 entre "x"
y realmente, esta ecuación parece bastante aterradora por que
tenemos "x" cuadrada, si "x" en el denominador pero vas a ver que si
simplificamos mucho esta expresión, vamos a llegar algo que al menos conocemos cómo resolver. Y lo primero que se me ocurre además de
copiar exactamente la misma ecuación,
se me ocurre que podemos multiplicar de ambos lados por "x" cuadrada. Digamos
multiplicamos todo esto por "x" cuadrada y también todo esto por
"x" cuadrada ¿Qué es lo que estoy ganando? Que al menos en el
denominador van a desaparecer las "x" cuadradas y ¿Qué es lo que me queda?
Me queda "x" cuadrada por 1 es "x" cuadrada más "x" cuadrada por 1 entre
"x" cuadrada, pues eso es simplemente 1 ¿Verdad? Para eso lo hice, y ahora del otro lado me queda 3 entre "x" por "x" cuadrada
esto es 3x.
Ahora sí pasamos el 3x del lado izquierdo restando, nos queda "x" cuadrada
-3x más 1 es igual a 0, y como ves este problema que en principio parecía bastante
complicado, ahora simplemente llegamos a una ecuación cuadrática ¿Verdad?
A una, a una ecuación de segundo grado muy bien, entonces esto no parece que se pueda factorizar ¿No? Por que
digamos que 2 números que multiplicados me den 1 pues, pues debería ser 1 y 1 ¿Verdad? -1 y - 1, y no
nos da - 3 la suma, así que vamos a tener que usar la fórmula
cuadrática. ¿Qué nos dice la fórmula cuadrática? Que las soluciones están dadas por - "b"
pero aquí "b" es todo este -3, así que si yo quiero - "b" va a ser
menos -3 que es 3
y sumamos.
Bueno tenemos más - la raíz de "b" cuadrada que es -3 al cuadrado es 9
- 4 "a" por "c" pero "a" es 1, "c" es 1
4 por "a"  por "c" es 4 simplemente, y todo esto lo dividimos entre 2a pero "a" es 1 entonces esto es 2.
¿Muy bien? Entonces esto solo para separarlo, tenemos 3/2 más - la raíz de 9 - 4 que es
5 sobre 2 ¿Muy bien? Entonces
nuestras 2 soluciones están dadas justamente por 3/2 más la raíz de 5 sobre 2 y también por
3/2 - la raíz de 5 sobre 2.
Ahí está escrito en la solución de los problemas que tengo aquí aparte.
Vamos con el siguiente, vamos con el ejercicio 33.
Dice "Hay dos números, dos números con las siguientes propiedades el segundo número es 3 más que el primero", entonces el
segundo número es el primero más 3.
¿Bien? 3 más que el primero. Ahora bien segunda propiedad, el producto de ambos números es 9 más que su suma. Entonces
el primero por el segundo es igual a 9 más, que es la suma, es decir 9 más que "p" más "s".
¿Muy bien? Muy bien entonces ya tenemos 2 ecuaciones, 2 incógnitas vamos a tratar de
resolverlo, y ¿Cómo vamos a hacerlo? Pues lo primero que se me ocurre, es hacer una sustitución. Tenemos que
"s" es "p" más 3 podemos sustituirlo aquí entonces, tenemos "p" que multiplica a "s" pero ese es "p" más 3
y esto debe ser igual a 9
más "p" más "s", pero "s" nuevamente es "p" más 3 ¿Ok?
Entonces ya con esto vamos a desarrollar, vamos a desarrollar, y "p" por "p" es "p" cuadrada más 3 por "p"
es 3p. Acá de este lado podemos agrupar este 9 y este 3, y nos da 12 y "p" más "p" son 2p.
El 2p digamos, restamos 2p de ambos lados, se cancela aquí y me queda "p" cuadrada más 3p
- 2 p, simplemente me queda una "p" es igual a 12, y ¿Qué si pasamos ahora el 12 restando del lado izquierdo?.
Tenemos "p" cuadrada más "p" - 12 es igual a 0.
Nuevamente llegamos a una ecuación
cuadrática ¿Verdad? Entonces esto sí se ve como que podemos factorizarlo.
Los números que multiplicados me den -12 y sumados 1, por ejemplo puede ser
-4 con 3, más 3
entonces -4 por 3 es -12 ,-4 más 3...
¿Ok? Quizás debemos cambiarle el signo, le cambiamos el signo para nada, ahora este es así,
y ahora sí
4 por -3 es -12 perdón, y 4 -3 es 1 muy bien. Entonces al
factorizarlo obtenemos esto, y esto sigue siendo igual a 0, entonces tengo un producto que es igual a 0.
¿Qué es lo que obtenemos? Que "p" es igual a -4 ¿Verdad? Simplemente de que este primer factor es 0,
si esto es 0, "p" es -4 o bien, este factor es 0 y eso quiere decir que "p" - 3 es 0,
lo que implica que "p" tiene que ser 3, entonces mi primer número o es -4 o es 3.
Vamos a regresarnos de este lado, si "p" es igual
a - 4 ¿Cuánto vale "s"?
"S" vale - 4 más 3 que es -1. Por otro lado si "p" vale 3,
¿Cuánto vale "s"? Pues si "p" es 3,
"s" es 3 más 3 que es 6, entonces dentro de las opciones que nos da la
página de donde estoy sacando, esto es la opción B es está ¡Muy bien!
Entonces vamos con el siguiente vídeo el perdón, con el siguiente ejercicio.
Laura está resolviendo la ecuación "x" cuadrada -8x igual a 9.
completando el binomio cuadrado ¿Qué número debería sumarse de ambos lados de la ecuación para completar el cuadrado?
Entonces además de que ya me estaba saltando a otro vídeo,
vamos a tratar de resolver este ejercicio. No sé dónde tengo la cabeza pero, bueno a ver.
Entonces lo que tenemos que hacer, es sumar algo de ambos lados para que podamos completar el binomio, para que se
complete el binomio cuadrado perfecto ¿Verdad? Entonces vamos a escribirlo. Esto es "x" cuadrada -8x
y voy a dejar un espacio para sumar algo y esto debe ser igual a 9.
Entonces sabemos que tenemos que sumar algo, para que este trinomio perdón, deberías decir siempre
trinomio, sea un cuadrado perfecto.
Debo sumar algo entonces
esencialmente es un número que
sumado consigo mismo me de - 8
y entonces lo que vamos a agregar aquí, es su cuadrado ¿Verdad? Tengo que pensar en un número
que sumado consigo mismo me de  -8 y entonces sumare aquí el cuadrado de ese número. Entonces
quien sumando consigo mismo es - 8 pues es - 4 ¿Verdad? Y si sumamos el cuadrado de eso, eso sería sumar
16 entonces, sumamos 16 de ambos lados y de esto me queda que esto es "x" -4 ¿Verdad? El número que dijimos
al cuadrado, y esto sería
25 ¿Muy bien? Entonces
en realidad el número que siempre hay que sumar, es el cuadrado
de esto a la mitad ¿Verdad? - 8 entre 2 es -4 al cuadrado es
16, y en realidad no nos pidieron resolver, solo nos preguntaron cuánto había que sumar, y aquí ya está, hay que sumarle
16 y que aquí es la respuesta B ¿Ok? Entonces es simplemente ¿Qué es lo que tenemos que hacer? Tenemos
una propuesta para hacer trinomio cuadrado perfecto, hay que sumarle la mitad de este número al
cuadrado ¿Verdad? Y la mitad de este fue -4 al cuadrado es
16 ¿Muy bien? Entonces
de ahí, de ahí de hecho es de donde viene la ecuación cuadrática ¿Verdad? Simplemente de completar el trinomio cuadrado perfecto.
Vamos con el último ejercicio de este vídeo ¿Cuál de las siguientes
describe de forma más precisa la traslación de la gráfica de "y" igual a"x" más 3 al cuadrado- 2,
a la gráfica de "y" igual a
"x" -2 al cuadrado más 2 ¿Ok? Y lo más fácil de ver siempre es el desplazamiento
en la coordenada "y"
déjenme hacer un dibujo,
más o menos ahí están mis ejes "x" y este es mi eje "y",
y lo que tenemos es, piensen por ejemplo en la, en la ecuación "y" igual a "x" cuadrada.
Entonces más o menos se ve como una parábola así ¿Verdad? Entonces ¿Quién sería "y" igual a
"x" cuadrada más 2?
Pues en 0 ahora va a valer 2, simplemente estamos trasladando 2 unidades hacia arriba ¿Verdad?
Bien entonces ahí está mi nueva parábola y piensen también en "y" igual a "x" cuadrada menos ok,
déjenme, déjenme quitar esto de aquí,
y no le hagan tanto caso a esto, y mejor lo ponemos junto a su gráfica. Esta es igual a "x" cuadrada
más 2, dónde pondrían ustedes la gráfica de "y" igual a "x" cuadrada -2 pues sería
trasladar hacia aquí abajo
donde, y cruza en -2 esta es "y"
igual a "x" cuadrada -2, entonces realmente pueden pensarlo de esa forma.
Tenemos algo al cuadrado - 2, que correspondería más o menos algo así y nos movemos a algo al cuadrado más 2.
Entonces nos trasladamos 2 unidades hacia arriba, y otras 2 hacia arriba, nos trasladamos 4 hacia arriba, entonces la respuesta podría ser
la A o l a B.
Ahora la que no es tan fácil de asimilar
es, cuál fue el desplazamiento en "x" y piensen por ejemplo en
la ecuación "y" igual a "x" más 3
al cuadrado ¿Ok? O cambiémosle el signo "x" -3 al cuadrado.
Si nosotros tenemos esta ecuación, ¿Qué es lo que vamos a obtener? Pues en donde
esto se hace 0 pues cuando "x" es igual a 3 ¿Verdad? Entonces
realmente donde pasa por 0 cuando "x" es igual a 3 entonces vamos a ver
algo así.
Que en "x" igual a 3 es 0 lo cual
bueno, es anti intuitivo
con el signo ¿Verdad? Si uno tiene aquí -3,  uno esperaría que estuviera del otro lado pero no, en realidad
estamos trasladando hacia la derecha, cuando le ponemos -3. Si ahora por ejemplo
Esto sería "y" igual a "x" -3 al cuadrado,
entonces si nosotros pensamos en "y"
igual a "x" más 3 al cuadrado ¿En qué número se anula? Pues cuando "x" es -3,
entonces andamos como por aquí.
Ahí es el único punto donde se anula, y entonces esa parábola "y" igual a "x" más 3
al cuadrado se ve de esta forma, entonces nosotros estamos pensando en estas 2 parábolas.
Tenemos "y" igual a "x" más 3 al cuadrado -2, entonces hay que trasladar -2 hacia abajo más o menos,
se vera algo así nuestra parábola.
Y por otro lado tenemos "x" - 2 al cuadrado más 2, el vértice
primero lo ubicamos en 2, más o menos como por aquí,
y luego trasladamos la parábola hacia arriba 2 unidades.
Entonces la parábola, las 2 parábolas que me interesan son más o menos éstas.
Más o menos entonces ¿Qué tanto trasladé? Pues aquí estamos en -3 y aquí es -2,
entonces en la posición vertical,
me trasladé
4 unidades ¿Verdad?
4 unidades y eso ya lo habíamos visto.
Ahora cuanto me trasladé hacia la derecha, a final de cuentas me trasladó hacia la derecha son 3,
hasta llegar al eje, y luego otros 2, por lo tanto me moví 5 a la derecha, y mi respuesta final
es la A.
Incluso si estás confundido con los traslados a la izquierda o a la derecha puedes ver que la diferencia
entre 3 y-2 es 5, y de ahí ya lo obtienes. Aunque yo esperaría que mejor comprendas la parte
geométrica. De todas formas nos vemos en el próximo vídeo.